day i'm going to be doing a family tree  of all of the siblings there are 10 of  us total and 3 were adopted these are my  parents and they've been together since  my mom was 17. and when they first got  married they adopted my cousin mary she  was around 15 16 at the time so then  mary moved out and they started having  more kids so then there's six of us then  they adopted my second cousin brian he  was 17 at the time that's him and then  they adopted chazz he was also around 16  17 at the time he went to my brother's  high school and then when i was 22 years  old i found out that my parents gave up  a kid for adoption when they were  teenagers so i was reunited with him  when i was 22 and that is him right  there and this is all of us together  except that's my brother's girlfriend  melissa she's not related to any of us